[Musique]
de nombreuses princesses là c'est de
livrer leurs corps d'albâtre aux
attouchements approximatif de tristes
dauphin dégénéré échangerait volontiers
leur prince charmant contre un plombier
charmant le plombier charmant est en
effet beaucoup plus virile
quoique légèrement plus salissant que le
prince charmant
lassé de livrer mon corps d'albâtre aux
attouchements approximatif dauphin
dégénère j'échangerais volontiers
chartrand plombier au couple quoique
légèrement plus salissant
mais direz vous comment faire pour
transformer une grenouille en plombier
charmant et bien c'est simple il suffit
de toucher la grenouille non pas avec
une baguette magique mais avec une clé
de douze magique
comment c'est simple regardez bien je
suis le plombier charmant c'est celle
plombier charmant etonnant non
[Musique]